bonsoir invitons kara merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur rt france
la cedeao menace donc de sanctionner les
opposants mais prône également la
constitution rapide d'un gouvernement
d'union nationale avec l'opposition avec
des élections législatives partielles
également elle exige aussi on l'a dit la
démission de 31 députés mal élu
qu'est-ce que vous tirer comme
conclusion de toutes ces annonces
concrètement dans notre proposition
naturellement mais les quelles
propositions ne correspondent pas aux
exigences du m51 qui est à l'origine de
cette situation politique délétère et
les maillots jaunes certes la question
de la salle bel et bien elle est sur
toutes les lèvres mais également les
membres monde
cela peut fonctionner les calmes et les
sorties les conclusions de la siedo
mêmes et d'aller même temps je pense
qu'il dit c'est qui aujourd'hui
demandent dévoilé que j'ai eu m 5
en aucun cas on ne peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les différentes
résolutions de la cedao on ne tenir
compte de ces différentes exigences de
qualité qu effectivement dans les
semaines à venir
owada les mois à venir les molécules
effectivement de se plonger davantage
dans cette situation sociopolitique qui
est aussi délectables encore en somme il
ya différentes et les solutions que ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il va y
avoir de nouvelles manifestations dans
les prochains jours c'est ce que vous
dites clairement qu elles mêmes liées à
la fête de tabaski
d'ailleurs les jeunes sont les nuits les
adm cinq prières lesquels j'ai
effectivement au baby et des nouvelles
sorties à partir du 3 août dans ce
chrono tels que vit ces différentes et
résolutions proposées parole a cédé aux
vies également l'insistance moment
l'exigence cas également les m5 au
vis-à-vis de ses différents clients sont
malheureusement on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les différentes
tentatives de médiation de la cedeao
n'ont aucunement permis aux des parties
de se rapprocher centaines de réponses
apportées à ces défense champs sur
lequel les moyens fort bloqué tant sur
les questions sécuritaires éducatif au
web institutionnel donc ça veut dire que
les mesures annoncées aujourd'hui par la
cedeao ne peuvent pas être
il en place on sait qu'alassane ouattara
par exemple a remis en cause la
crédibilité de la cedeao est ce qu'elle
est crédible la cedeao avec ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui le milieu membres
décédés ou naturellement laissé 10
pillon l'impulsion par des différentes
milices effective à la vidéo il est
déchirante demandes formulées par les
pays membres notamment des ces
différentes et a malheureusement sont
difficilement satisfaites par les
divisions successives la cedeao si l'on
prend le cas précis du projet les m5
tout quand même un certain nombre de
facteurs à la fois religieuses s'étaient
civil même politique d'ailleurs mais
lequel lesquels 25 des membres plutôt la
dissolution de l'assemblée
or la cedao des membres est essentiel
dans les circonscriptions imposant sa
portée par la cedao est loin de
satisfaire les actes et qui sont à
l'origine de ce mois les monnaies
légalement si vous regardez la manette
dans la vidéo on voit le démembrement
des déchirements du classement
les neuf sages n'est pas de cette façon
également le n 5 en 1 rivoire
cette conscience dans le contexte de ce
prix que la cdc un nombre important
comme un coup d'état
le calcul malheureusement certains
légitime on les différents pôles dans
tous les champs du possible de ce décret
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la question de la
voir la légitimité de cette institution
elle se pose avec acuité la crise
malienne est ce qu'elle peut être
résolue tant que la situation au sahel
reste chrétien qui naturellement une
connexion de facteurs c'est le pape ou
vieille dame un cube où ça va tellement
bien non la france s'y risque souligne
le haut fait peut on attend un peu
d'effets domino
je m'étais variable
les exceptions sont l'objet les
deschamps sait que le temps moyen n'est
pas de cheminot n'est pas de l'état
égale moi et je pouvais les et les
prédications vous pouvez dès très
fragilisée et les policiers critiqués
pouvoir contester la politique donc en
somme l'histoire il ya des façons de
vivre et le gouvernement notamment de la
cdo et les défenses population il y
avait quand même un décalage entre le
gouvernement et le gouvernement public
tellement on la femme comme édition que
l'acide héros notamment à travers ses
différents chefs départ c'est dans une
semaine et demie c'est le danger sur
tous les mouvements des calomnies à
l'otan pour les enfants dès lors
qu'elles soient lents tels qu elles sont
munies de l'atvs les différentes
provinces qui sont prises ou les
méchantes promesses qui sont justement
annoncer nous faut c'est que vous venez
vous joindre le contexte n est pas un
délit du challenge pour partie malienne
merci à l'est tounkara d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
sociologue et directeur du centre des
études sécuritaires et stratégiques au
sahel